翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Takafusa Kitazume
こんにちは
これ 何だと思いますか？
ゲームの中の秘宝じゃありません
日よけです
こんなに穴だらけで
日よけになるのかと思うかもしれませんが
夏のお昼時には
ちゃんと日陰になるんです
太陽が動くと 光がちょっと
漏れてくるんですが
木陰みたいな感じで気持ちが良いんです
今日はこんなものを なんで
僕が作ろうと思ったかっていう話です
この日よけの研究は僕の人生の中で
目茶苦茶面白かった研究なんですが
最初からこんなものを作ろうと
思っていたわけではありません
最初は 都会は何で暑いのか？
ということを考えていたんです
都会が周囲の郊外よりも暑くなる現象を
ヒートアイランドといいます
ヒートアイランドというと
みなさんは夏の暑い昼間の気温を
思い浮かべると思います
ですが 実際には 昼間の気温は
田舎も都会もほとんど変わりません
ヒートアイランドが顕著に見えるのは
夜なんです
でも実際問題として
夏暑いときに都会にいると
暑く感じますよね
そういうデータもあります
[街の地表面は熱い]
これは京都の地表面温度です
衛星写真で衛星から撮った
地表面温度です
昼間の温度です
これを見るとやっぱり
都会が暑いということが分かります
地面が熱いと何が起こるかというと
熱い地面から赤外線がやってきます
その赤外線は熱い路面に立っている人間に
大体100Wくらいの熱を熱を余計に与えます
100Wというと どのくらい熱いか
ちょっと想像つかないかもしれませんけど
大体この使い捨てカイロ１枚１Wです
100Wで これ100枚分です
これで暑くないわけないですよね？
ですから 実は 街の昼間 暑いのは
気温が高いからではなくて
暑い路面からの赤外線が強いからなんです
じゃあ街は何故そんなに地表面が
熱くなっちゃうんでしょうか？
[建物や道路は大きい]
[葉っぱは小さい]
街の表面と田舎の表面と
地表面を見比べてみると
田舎の方は
小さい葉っぱで覆われています
それに対して 都会は
大きなビルであるとか 道路
大きな面で覆われています
そんなのは温度と関係ないと思うかも
しれませんが これ 大ありなんです
夏の炎天下に 車を置いておくと
とても熱くなってしまうことは
皆さんよくご存知ですが
このミニカーは熱くなりません
小さいものは
空気に熱を逃す効率が良いので
熱くならないんです
よく見ると 葉っぱって
これくらいの大きさですよね
本当にこんなことが
起こるのか？というのを
さっきの衛星画像で見てみましょう
左下の方に白いところ
つまり熱いところがあります
これは何かというと
自衛隊の駐屯地です
大きな屋根のある大きな建物があります
別に中で爆弾作っている訳ではないんです
（笑）
もっと北の方にやっぱり熱いところがあります
これは何かというと 自動車工場です
大きな屋根を持つ
巨大な建物が並んでます
やっぱり大きな面は熱くなっちゃう
ってことがわかります
もう一つ見てみましょう
今度は右下の方です
これは山の中なんですが
これは何かって言うと
ゴルフ場です
ゴルフ場の芝が熱いんです
芝の葉っぱって 小さいですよね
今 小さなものは熱くならないって
言ったばかりなんですが
熱は空気に逃がしますから
風通しが必要なんです
芝は地面に密生していいて
風が通らないので
熱くなっちゃうんです
こういう大きな木はというと
小さな葉が三次元的にばらまかれていて
風通しが良いので熱くならないんです
こういう風通しの良さを実現するには
どういう構造になっていたらいいか？
というので登場するのが
このシェルピンスキー四面体です
このシェルピンスキー四面体は
面積はあるんだけど体積はないという
不思議な性質を持っています
紙のように面積がありますから
光を遮ることができます
でも体積がありませんから
スカスカで風がよく通ります
なんか良く分からなく
なってきたと思いますから
フラクタルの説明をしたいと思います
いまミニーマウスの写真がここにあります
50％縮小した写真を３枚撮ります
１枚の面積は４分の１ですから
３枚で４分の３です
ちょっと小さくなりました
これ 全体をまた同じようにコピーを取ります
４分の３の４分の３で
また小さくなります
これをどんどん繰り返します
どんどんどんどん繰り返して
無限回繰り返すと
面積がゼロになっちゃいます
これ 100年くらい前の
シェルピンスキーという数学者が考えたもので
シェルピンスキーのガスケット
といわれています
でもこれは当時の数学者でも
なんだかよく分からなかったので
悪魔図形と言われたそうです
でも実はこの悪魔
皆さんの周りにいっぱいあります
はい 今度は山際（やまぎわ）先生
（笑）
山際先生のコピーを取りたいと思いますが
４枚取ります
ちょっとこれとコピーの取り方を変えます
４枚ですが 一番下は
なぜか非常にやせ細っちゃった山際先生です
これ全体をまた同じように
コピーを取っていきます
いま 山際先生が４人
山際先生が16人 山際先生が64人
えー 256人 1024人
どんどんいきます どんどんどんどんいって
山際先生がどんどん小さくなります
（笑）
さあ これ 何でしょう？
葉っぱですよね
これは世界人口を超える山際先生から成る
葉っぱなんですが
（笑）
本物より本物っぽい
さっきのシェルピンスキーのガスケットは
悪魔と呼ばれましたが
これは悪魔どころじゃなくて
もう実に自然な図形です
でもこれはコピーの取り方を
ちょっと変えただけで
この２つは同じ図形の仲間なんです
この木と このシェルピンスキー四面体
同じようなものに見えてきたでしょうか？
一見して全然違う形に見えるかもしれませんが
共通点があるんです
それで もしかしたら
このシェルピンスキー四面体が
木の代わりになるかもしれない
と思って実験してみました
まずは平らなトタン屋根
炎天下で屋根が熱くなっちゃいますから
そこから赤外線が出て
その下で昼寝していても暑いです
で フラクタル日よけです
日よけの温度全然上がりません
ですから赤外線がこなくて
風が通りますから
気持ちよく昼寝ができます
こういう日よけで街を覆ってしまえば
街が森のようになって
暑くならないんじゃないか
と思って作ってみたのが
この一番最初にお見せした
このフラクタル日よけなんです
これは口で説明しても なかなか
わかっていただけないんですが
実際にここへ行くと
ちょっと涼しくて気持ちが良いんです
学会でも最初は全く相手にされませんでした
でも最近は少しずつ拡がりつつあります
このフラクタル日よけの話をすると
なんでこんなことを思いついたんですか？
とよく言われます
実は私がこんなことを思いついたのは
素人だったからです
私の専門は建築学でも数学でもありません
太陽物理学です
全然関係ないです
いろいろ事情があって
専門とは違うことをやることになり
そのときに自分の手で観測して
自分の手で実験をして
なんか測ってみるまでは
勉強をしないでおこうと
決めたんです
だって研究って
人がやらないことをやることです
自分がやってみる前に勉強しちゃったら
人と同じ発想しか
出なくなっちゃうじゃないですか？
新しいことをやるときに
知らないことっていうのは
知らないということは
非常に強い武器なんです
それも一生に一回しか使えない武器です
こんな貴重な武器を
使う前に捨てちゃうっていうのは
もったいないでしょう？
素人ですから
研究の設備もありませんでした
お金もありませんでした
ではどうするか？
もうほとんど全部手作りです
例えばこれ
気温を測るときにに使う
百葉箱みたいなものですが
これを買うと結構高いです
ですが プラスチックの板を買ってきて
ホットプレートで温めて 柔らかくして
ビールの缶で形を作ると（笑）
300円くらいでできちゃいます
自分で作ると 教科書で勉強するよりも
はるかに沢山のことが
非常によくわかります
当然ですが
このフラクタル日よけも全部手作りです
というか こんなもの 売ってませんから
作るしかないんです
材料と工具は
全部ホームセンターで買ってきました
そもそも研究とは
人がやらないことをやることです
必要なものはお金で
買えるわけないじゃないですか
研究にとって一番大事なのは
お金じゃないんです
暇です（笑）
その暇をふんだんに使って
綿密に計画を立てたのかというと
全然そんなことありません
計画なんてほとんどありませんでした
そもそも 研究って
分からないことをやるんですね
明日自分が何を思いつくか
分かんないじゃないですか
新しいことを思いついちゃったら
今まで考えたことが
無意味になっちゃうかもしれません
だから思いついたことを
片っぱしから やりました
半年後に自分が何をやっているか
自分でも全く想像がつきませんでした
完全に行き当たりばったりなんですが
めちゃくちゃ面白かったです
ではお金がなくて 計画もなくて
どうするのか？と
もう 偶然です（笑）
全く他力本願に聞こえるかもしれませんが
そもそも研究って分からないことを
分からないから やるんですよね
どこに答えがあるか分からないんです
だから答えも思わぬところから やってきます
実は このミニカーが
熱くならないということも
とんでもないところから やってきました
あるとき
[労働安全衛生法による免許証]
こういう資格を取らなきゃならなくなりました
30年ぶりに受験勉強をしました
この受験勉強をしているときに
このミニカーが熱くならない
ということに気がついたんです
気象学の勉強でも
都市工学の勉強でもありません
しかも この事実は実は古い教科書に
ちゃんと書いてありました
僕が見つけたものではないです
このシェルピンスキー四面体
これを日よけに使うことを思いついたのも
まったくの偶然からでした
ある数学の先生が
このシェルピンスキー四面体に
時計台の写真を貼り付けて
真正面から見ると
時計台がちゃんと見えるんですが
角度をかえると
ばらばらになっちゃってよくわからない
面白いでしょう？って
正直言って意味がわかりませんでした（笑）
あの 数学者って暇ですねー
って言っちゃいました（笑）
でもうちに帰って夜
布団に入って
ひょっとして 木ってこんなもんじゃないの？
と思いついたんです
お金がないことも
計画がないことも
偶然のチャンスに
出会う確率を上げてくれます
でも 問題はその偶然のチャンスを
いかに確実に掴むかっていうことです
こういうのを
セレンディピティっていうんですが
これが結構 難しい
心に余裕がないとできません
常に自然体の構えが必要なんです
フラクタル日よけを見ていると
つくづく思うことがあります
それは 自然は完璧を目指さないっていうことです
フラクタル日よけって実に中途半端な存在で
日よけって言いながら
なんと光が漏れちゃうんです
雨も風も防げません
なんか 間抜けなんです
でも 自然は多分そういう不完全なところを
逆に利用してるんだと思います
多分これが自然のありようなんだと思います
人間はこういう不完全さとか間抜けさに
なんとなく本能的に
心地良さを感じてないでしょうか？
多分そういうとき
偶然の中から
なんかチャンスを見つけるセンサーが
凄く感度が
高くなってる気がするんです
我々は
完璧を目指しすぎていないでしょうか？
ちゃんと勉強して
立派な計画を立てて
真面目に仕事すれば
イノベーションが起こると
思ってないでしょうか？
人間も自然の中に生きてますから
そう簡単にはいきません
イノベーションというのは
真面目の外にあるもんだと思います
フラクタル日よけって
そんなことを教えてくれる
ような気がするんです
フラクタル日よけって
中途半端で 適当なんですが
なんとなく自然で気持ちが良い
これを見ていると
細かいことを考えるのが
バカバカしくなって
「まいいか」という気になってきます
私はこのフラクタル日よけが
世の中に広がって
都市が少しでも快適に
暮らせるようになったら
嬉しいと思うんですが
それと一緒に この不完全で
中途半端で 適当でも
「ま いいか」っていう気分が
広がってくれたらと思います
そうすると この堅苦しい世の中が
ちょっと楽になるんじゃないかと思います
そして偶然の中から
チャンスを見つけるセンサーが働き出します
みなさんも もし
このフラクタル日よけを見つけたら
その下へ行って
思いっきり肩の力を抜いて
「ま いいか」って呟いてみてください
そうしたら気分が楽になって
なんか思いつくかもしれません
ありがとうございました
（拍手）